I transmitted them into your mind you TR
the Cyberman no he didn't no he
didn't no he didn't and if he did then
you screwed it up
because
nothing nothing that went on in
Ascension of the Cybermen indicated at
any point that the doctor was seeing
experiencing or remembering any of this
it just goes in and out of them they're
just in there willy-nilly but it's never
ever framed like the doer going ah and
then like cutting it like it's something
that she's remembering she never
acknowledges that she's having this
thing she never like shakes her head
clear or any of it there is nothing
about the framing in the way that any of
that stuff last episode was presented
that made it look like she was also
seeing it so no transmitted them into
your mind you the no you didn't